مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه
الخاصه من برنامج حوار على فروزن هذه
الحلقه ستكون على جزئين سنتوقف فيها عند
ابرز احداث 2022 وانعكاساتها على العالم
العربي كما سنتطرق للدور الفرنسي في صناعه
الاحداث مع ضيف الديبلوماسيه الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
كبيره من هذا العدوان وهي تتجاوز ذلك
لانها سببت ازمه في الطاقه في كل انحاء
العالم تعاني منها الكثيب البلدان بما
فيها البلدان الجنوب واظهرت ان القواعد
اليوم بين البلدان او لدينا تساؤل بشان
تصرفاته القوى الكبرى ما الذي سيحصل
الاموره
للولايات المتحده همم اظهرت ان تصميم
الولايات المتحده والبلدان الغربيه لا
يزال قويه في دعم اوكرانيا اوكرانيا بلد
اوروبي على حدودنا ومن الطبيعه انه يساعده
الاوروبي في هذه الحرب
الى عدد العقوبات التي اعتمدت ضد روسيا اه
والتي مع الوقت سيكون لها دورا كبيرا لا
ننسى انه ان لم يتم التوصل الى حل مرضا
للاوكرانيين اولا فان روسيا
ستصير على المدى الطويل بلدا مارقا وستعان
اقتصاديا البلدان الاوروبيه بصدد تحويل
الطريقه
وروسيا مضطره اليوم
منخفضه للصين
هنا يعني هل كان لدى اوروبا يعني همم
امكانيه للتملص من تلك الحرب ام يعني انها
فرضت عليها
الاوروبيون في هذه الحاله وخلافه لما ظنه
الرئيس بوتين
استثنائيه وذلك لانه لا يمكننا اليوم في
القرن ال 21 ان نتصرف كما يتصرف رئيس
بوتين
رده فعل الاوروبيه في عدم الانخراط
العسكري اي عدم الدخول في نزاعه مع روسيا
لكن من الطبيعي ان نساعد بلد
يتعرض للعدوان ان نساعده من الطبيعي ذلك
بالعوده الى مساله الطاقه همم ما الحل هل
من مخرج لهذه الازمه
لم نخرج من الازمه
في طريقه امداد الطاقه في اوروبا
لا يمكن تغيير الامور بين ليله وضحاها
طبعا لن نشتري همم النفط والغاز الروسي
ولكن هذا سيجري على مراحل وينبغي العثور
على موردين اخرين هنالك مواريدون اخرون
قال الولايات المتحده تبيعه لاوروبا كميات
من الغاز
قطر واستراليا وبلدان الاخرى طبعا هذا
سيكون على حساب بقى المصالح الروسيه ولكن
الروس هم الذين اخذوا هذه المسؤوليه
بالنسبه
للخلفيه قضيه الفساد التي عصبت بالاتحاد
الاوروبي همم
ممكن قطر رد على نقطه واحده عندما يتهم
بالفساد فقد ذكرت قطر انه عندما نكون
شركاء ينبغي تجنب اهانه الشريك هذا لا
يعني انه كان هنالك قرار قطري بوقفي امداد
الغاز هنالك من طرف ماذا يجري همم في
عمليات التحقيق الهمم الجاريه وهذا امر
يقع تحت مسؤوليه العداله والعداله ستبد
بذلك اما امداد الغاز القطري الى اوروبا
لا يزال جاريا
[موسيقى]
بالحديث عن الخليج الخليج يعني هو كما
تحدثت يعني من ضمن المصدرين المصدرين
للطاقه واضح هناك ثلاث تنافس يعني امريكي
صيني
كان هناك زياره للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
وكان فيه هناك قمه خليجيه صينيه يعني
كفت من سترجع عند الخليجيين يعني هل يعني
كفتين
الموليه اللي همم
الولايات المتحده قد تغيرت لم تعد القوه
المهيمنه السابقه ودخلنا في عالم متعدد
الاقصاب وهذه البلدان الخليج طبيعي
هذه البلدان ترغب بمواصله العامه مع الصين
لان الصين لديها حاجه للغاز والبترول
والتكنولوجيا الصينيه تهم بلدان الخليج
ومن الواضح ان هذا التعاون مع الصين
سيتطوره
البلدان تنتظره بلدان الخليج
هو البعد الامني في وجهه ايران تحت حمايه
غربيه وبلدان
عنها لان الصين ما يهممها هو الطاقه ان
كان من السعوديه او من ايران
الصينيون لن ياتوا
للدفاع عن بلدان الخليج ان كان هنالك
عدوان ايراني فقط
ليس هناك فقط الولايات المتحده الولايات
المتحده هي الشريك الرئيسي الامني لدول
الخليج ولكن فرنسا لديها قاعده في ابو ظبي
ولدينا اتفاقات دفاعيه مع عدد من البلدان
في المنطقه
وسيكون لنا دور في حال ظهور مشكله ولكن
بلدان الخليج تعول على الولايات المتحده
وفيما يتجاوز البعد الامني هنالك علاقه
قديمه ولا سيامه مع السعوديه ولا يمكن
هي علاقات تاريخيه انسانيه اقتصاديه
والولايات المتحده مهتمه باسواق الخليج
بسبب بسيط حاليا هنالك تباطؤ اقتصادي فيها
اوروبا
المنطقه الوحيده في العالم ذات الافاق
وذات العقول هي منطقه الخليج والولايات
المتحده ليس في نيتها ان تتخلى عن علاقتها
مع بلدان الخليج حتى ولو ان العالم تلقى
بين لاداره الرئيس بايدن والحكومه
السعوديه ليست في افضل احوالها وهذا لا
يعني انا بلدان الخليج ستختار الصين
والمصالح الاقتصاديه هي من الجانب الصيني
ولكن يعرفون ان سياسيا
وتكنولوجيا واقتصاديا من صالح
الولايات المتحده
هناك اضطرابات داخل ايران هناك
نووي ايران والخليج ايران ودوره في العراق
وسوريا وبقيه الدول العربيه بالحديث عن
الخليج دعنا نتحدث قليلا عن يعني همم
همم عن الدور الايراني في هذه المنطقه
يعني همم هل همم الى اين ستتجاهله الامور
واضحه
الغزو الامريكي للعراق استفاد الايرانيون
من تزعزع التوازنات الاقليميه ودخلوا هذا
ما يقولون في اربعه بلدان عربيه هي العراق
وسوريا ولبنان
واليمنها
الحفاظ على هذا التاثير همم في هذه
البلدان
لا بوتيك همم جوجل
الايرانيات في العراق وحزب الله في لبنان
والحوثيين في اليمن
ثوره شعبيه
اييه ايران طبقات الشعبيه التي كانت تدعم
النظام بدات تترنح من الصعب
التنبؤ بالامور ولكن
السلطه الايرانيه في وضع صعب الاتفاق
الايراني النووي ليس تقدم بشانه لان
الحكومه المحافظه لا تود فتح البلاد لانها
تخشى من فقدان مكاسبها ومن الواضح ان
الايراني
هامه ولكن هل هي اكبر قوه في العالم لست
اكيدا والوضع الحالي في الصين اقتصاديه
التي ستحدث في روسيا مع فشل تدخلها
وعملياتها في اوكرانيا فان الايرانيين
ينبغي ان يفكر بمصالحهم
[موسيقى]
عن سيطره
الحكومه
تسيطر على الوضع لا تزال
وتستخدموه اساليب قمعيه مخجله ولكن الامر
الجديد هو ان همم الاحتجاجات لا تتراجع
ونرى ان هناك شريحه واسعه من المجتمع
الايراني تودد تغيير النظام
اعتقد ان النظام مع الوقت همم
وضعه ليس واضحه همم
لا نعرف اي شيء تاخذوا وقتها همم
في الشرق الاوسط يعني في وقت التحول فيه
باريس اخذ الدور من خلال قرب من بغداد هذا
الملف وعلاقه فرنسا مع دول الخليجيه وشمال
افريقيا في الجزء الثاني من برنامج حوار
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]